[Music]
on this friday night
twas the warning a week before christmas
a reminder to canadians to stay the
course numbers continue to head
in the wrong direction the top doc's
advice on what needs to be done
right now cleaner and better or dirty
and dangerous the controversy over a
form of nuclear power
plus a week-long nightmare ends in
nigeria
i was crying cry of joy freedom for
hundreds of kidnapped boys
and misery loves company the storm that
stranded a thousand commuters
overnight
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we are one week from christmas and this
will be a holiday season
unlike any other there is one message
that is consistent across the country
officials from coast to coast to coast
are urging canadians
to stay home for any celebrations there
are more than 75
000 active covenant 19 cases in canada
huge parts of the country are under
lockdowns
today the prime minister gave canadians
a reason for optimism in 2021.
hundreds of thousands of vaccine doses
are expected to arrive
early in the new year but justin trudeau
says people must continue to follow
public health guidelines now
more than ever our fight against this
virus is not
over even as we're preparing to say
goodbye and
good riddance to 2020.
it may be the holiday season but we have
to be more careful than ever
the ontario government is extending
strict lockdown measures for hot spots
including toronto and neighboring peel
region
ontario reported the most new cases of
any province today
more than 2200 and 40 more deaths
on monday premier doug ford will
announce new measures to fight the spike
in cases
after his government holds an emergency
meeting over the weekend
michael couture has our top story
tonight
i believe that in many areas of the
country
stricter measures should be put in place
as soon as possible it is not what
anyone wanted to hear the week before
christmas
but canada's chief public health officer
is worried the curve isn't bending and
that's leading
to something worse and i think the
indicator that is most troubling
of course are the hospitalizations in
the intensive care
occupancy because that's related to
something that happened
at least two weeks ago the trends we're
seeing
throughout ontario we're very very
concerned ontario premier doug ford was
expected to announce stricter measures
friday but instead
he's meeting with the ceos of the
province's hospitals over the weekend to
hear about what's happening on the
ground
he did however foreshadow what could be
coming
as for the lockdowns in the areas that
are locked down right now that are
expiring on monday
i can tell you they won't be expiring
with that province and the entire
country in need of some holiday
cheer prime minister justin trudeau
delivered an early christmas gift
but it's marked do not open until the
new year
in january we'll be getting 125
000 doses of the pfizer vaccine per week
in total
half a million doses should be shipped
to canada in the first month of 2021
and pfizer is sending another 5 000
doses this month
meaning we'll have 255 000 shots
in december still the prime minister is
reminding people
getting a vaccine in a month doesn't
prevent you from getting coveted 19
tomorrow
so he's appealing to canadians to have
virtual gatherings this year
we also want to be able to see them and
give them big hugs
next christmas and our capacity to have
them
here with us next christmas depends on
all of us
thinking about doing our part this
christmas and in the coming
months of this winter a reminder that
the sooner we follow public health
guidelines
the sooner we can get back to normal
life
robin mike looks like a good tour in
ottawa thanks mike a kova 19
outbreak has hit another cargill meat
packing plant
this one in guelph ontario the company
says at least 82 people have the virus
and the facility is temporarily closed
in the spring cargill's high river
alberta plant was forced to close when
nearly half of the 2000 workers
tested positive for kova 19. two
employees
died a class action lawsuit has been
filed against the company
quebec's health minister is imploring
residents to limit their social contacts
as coven 19 infections and
hospitalizations rise
today the province reported over 1700
new cases
and 36 more deaths there are now more
than a thousand people in hospital
because of coven 19.
a 50 rise in the past three weeks today
there was a stern message for
anyone thinking of skirting the rules
if quebecers do not respect those rules
during the holidays
and increase the contacts ever thought
for all those who have been at the front
since spring to those men and women who
make sacrifice
every day for you in the u.s tonight the
food and drug administration has
approved the moderna vaccine for
emergency use
it is desperately needed this month
alone more than 42 thousand americans
have died from covet 19.
today vice president mike pence became
the highest ranking elected official
to receive the pfizer biontech vaccine
and as jennifer johnson explains
he's encouraging other americans to
follow suit
calling it a medical miracle u.s vice
president mike pence the head of the
white house coronavirus task force
received the coven 19 vaccine pence
along with his wife and surgeon general
jerome adams were inoculated on camera
to show americans there's nothing to
fear as the christmas holiday approaches
this is always a season of hope
we gather here today at the end of a
historic week
to affirm to the american people that
hope is on the way
u.s president donald trump hasn't said
if he'll get the vaccine
president-elect joe biden plans to be
inoculated monday
pence has now joined millions of health
care workers nursing home residents
and elderly veterans receiving the
pfizer biontech vaccine
a chance to take it take it following a
recommendation from an advisory panel
the u.s food and drug administration
plans to fast track a second vaccine
from moderna
with over 6 million doses delivered to 3
200 locations within days
but the vaccine won't help hospitals
overwhelmed right now
all in southern california are out of
icu beds
we are getting so many covenant patients
that we have to take over a part of the
emergency department
to take care of them big pharmacy chains
have announced plans to hit the road
with mobile clinics to reach people in
rural areas
to vaccinate low-income and elderly
americans we're going to do everything
we can to be sure
that people living in vulnerable
communities and minorities
get all the resources that they need as
america's death toll climbs over 310
000 federal health experts are again
asking people to stay home this
christmas holiday
as we go from december the end of the
month
new year's and into january we may yet
see
again a surge upon a surge but the
american automobile association predicts
85 million people will travel this
holiday season
most by car that's a drop of nearly
one-third from a year ago
but still a massive migration in the
midst of this pandemic
jennifer johnson global news washington
here in canada the prime minister has
said he'll wait his turn before rolling
up his sleeve
justin trudeau plans to get vaccinated
when other healthy people
in their 40s are eligible and while
there are arguments to the contrary
as abigail beeman tells us experts say
that's the right call
94 year old queen elizabeth and her 99
year old husband are likely among the
first in line for the vaccine
72 year old prince charles who recovered
from copen 19
reportedly says he's further down the
list it's kind of an ethical minefield
bioethicist carrie bowman says there are
different ways to look at the question
of whether leaders should be vaccinated
first
and the u.s is favoring the national
security approach by having a number of
high-profile politicians get the shot
the rollout is happening faster there
than in canada where justin trudeau is
waiting his turn
in this year of 2020 we have very very
few vaccines
and we have large numbers of vulnerable
people so i would say that the prime
minister is correct
on that getting the vaccines out to the
people that
uh or in the greatest line of uh of
danger
with getting uh infected um that to me
is
is the important thing to do and frankly
i think it's the it's the canadian thing
to do
there is a balance leaders and
celebrities want to take down vaccine
hesitancy by rolling up their sleeves
i would encourage everybody to to do the
sensible thing not just for themselves
but for everybody else it's not a new
idea elvis got the polio shot on
television for the same reason in 1956
and before he became president thomas
jefferson was vaccinated for smallpox
the beginning of vaccinations as we know
it we have got to reach a threshold
more or less around 70 percent of the
population
if we feel vaccine hesitancy is is
compromised in any way getting prominent
people to get it is a good idea
absolutely not now not until canada has
more doses
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the united nations-backed initiative
known as kovacs has gained access to
nearly two billion doses of vaccine
to help countries in need these
unprecedented agreements mean
that all 190 countries and economies
participating in kovacs
will be able to access vaccines to
protect vulnerable groups
in their populations during the first
half of next year
this is fantastic news and a milestone
in global health
the deal brings together several
pharmaceutical makers but it does not
include the moderna or pfizer biontech
vaccines
the program hopes to eventually reach an
agreement with them several countries
have made pledges to kovacs including
canada
ottawa has promised 75 million dollars
to support vaccine delivery in lower
income
economies and today the prime minister
received praise from the who
for committing to share surplus doses
a kova 19 outbreak has hit the edmonton
hockey bubble ahead of the world juniors
the international ice hockey federation
confirmed eight players from germany
and two from sweden have tested positive
for covet 19
while preparing for the junior hockey
championship in the edmonton bubble
the tournament is scheduled to start on
christmas day the federation says
all german players will quarantine until
thursday on friday the team goes up
against finland
startling numbers out of the u.s show
prisoners are being hit hard by covid19
new data collected by the associated
press and the marshall project
shows one in every five inmates has
tested positive for the virus
that rate is more than four times as
high as the general population
in some states including kansas arkansas
and south dakota
more than half of the prisoners have
been infected more than 1700 have died
new coven 19 cases and prisons reached
their highest level this week
since testing began in the spring
the former clerk of bc's legislature
craig james is facing charges of fraud
and breach of trust
over an alleged spending scandal james
was one of the top legislative officials
in the province when the allegations
surfaced
he's accused of billing taxpayers for
personal travel expenses
clothing luggage and a wood splitter
you'll defend yourself vigorously
against these charges no question
you do plan to plead not guilty just be
clear i can't say
police conducted an investigation over
two years and a special prosecutor was
appointed prior
to the charges being laid rcmp in nova
scotia will use a helicopter to search
for five missing fishermen
believed to have drowned in rough seas
in the bay of fundy on tuesday
the mounties have partnered with the
department of lands and forestry which
owns the helicopter
to continue the search from the air a
heavy snowstorm
suspended the search along the shoreline
yesterday close to where the 15-meter
boat capsized
one body was recovered tuesday night
there is some good news out of the
retail sector tonight sales rose by 0.4
in october to 54.6 billion dollars
that's the sixth straight monthly
increase since the record drop in april
that's near the start of the pandemic
statistics canada says the growth was
led by the sale of motor vehicles
and car parts an energetic debate coming
up the battle over using nuclear power
in canada
plus the emergency in fiji the
consequences of a devastating cyclone
and going nowhere fast when a roadway
becomes
a parking lot
they're known as small modular reactors
or smrs
this is a relatively new kind of nuclear
power plant that can be used in ships
in remote northern communities or to
power resource development
like mines the federal government wants
canada to be a world leader in
developing smrs
as david aiken reports the technology
could help canada cut harmful greenhouse
gas emissions
some smrs small modular reactors are
small enough to fit in your kitchen most
fit in the back of a truck
they're used to power submarines
aircraft carriers and icebreakers
but ottawa and some provincial
governments think smrs could do much
more displace dirty diesel as the energy
source heating remote arctic communities
or
power energy intensive mining or oil
sands operations
smrs are neither a distraction nor are
they a silver bullet
this is not the government of canada
going all in on one option this is the
government of canada ensuring
that we have every tool possible in our
toolbox
to reach net zero carbon emissions
decarbonizing electricity systems is the
building block
of decarbonizing all other sectors and
we are going to need
two to three times more electricity
clean electricity and clean electricity
than we have
today governments have already spent
millions developing smr
technology and they'll need to spend
more because it still needs lots of work
deploying the first canadian smrs may be
eight or nine years away
and the idea is controversial the green
party the block quebecois and the ndp
all oppose this focus on nuclear smrs
the government narrative about you know
this is what's going to get
remote indigenous first nations
communities off of diesel
those communities don't want to deal
with nuclear power they want to deal
with
our technologies that they can
understand
and manage themselves and many civil
society groups are also
opposed and object to nuclear power
being labeled as
clean technology when in fact it's
contained
technology it's containing the dirtiest
most dangerous
substance known to known on the on the
planet
which is radioactive used radioactive
fuel
but the trudeau government is convinced
that nuclear power including
smrs must be a part of canada's energy
mix
in a sustainable economy we cannot take
nuclear off the table we need nuclear
there's no getting to net zero by 2050
without it david aiken global news
ottawa america's nuclear stockpile
is secure despite the department of
energy becoming the latest u.s
agency to be embroiled in a cyber
security breach
the department says the hack was
isolated to its business networks
hackers believed to be affiliated with
russia installed a malicious code into
software known as solarwinds
it's used to monitor u.s government
networks the fbi
is now investigating how the thieves
managed to target other federal
departments
including homeland security treasury and
commerce
still ahead traffic is bad in tokyo but
this jam trapped hundredth
for days
torrential rain and winds up to 285
kilometers per hour
battered fiji overnight at least two
people were killed when cyclone yasa
struck as a category 5 storm now a
category 2
is dumping heavy rain across the islands
scores of homes have been destroyed
damage is expected to cost hundreds of
millions of dollars
fiji's prime minister says the disaster
is a climate
emergency
these road crews in japan had their work
cut out for them they had to clear a
highway where at one point about a
thousand vehicles were trapped
some for two days it started wednesday
when a vehicle got stuck
in the snow that triggered a major
traffic jam that stretched 15 kilometers
on the kanetsu expressway which connects
tokyo to negada in the north
the forecast is calling for heavy snow
throughout the weekend
residents across the northeastern u.s
are now dealing with frigid temperatures
as they dig out from that monster
snowstorm
up to a meter of snow fell in some
regions it was one of the biggest winter
storms on record
temperatures are now falling below zero
making conditions dangerously slick
a new storm is expected to travel across
the u.s christmas week
it'll bring heavy rain and thunderstorms
to the west coast
turning to snow and ice as it moves east
relief for parents of those kidnapped
students now free in nigeria
up next the calls to bring back those
still missing
finally tonight there is some good news
from nigeria
more than 300 schoolboys who were
kidnapped last week have been freed
the government says their release was
secured through negotiations
it's no doubt a relief for the parents
but it's a reminder of another abduction
six years ago and some of those children
never returned
here's redmond shannon
hundreds of school boys saved after an
unimaginable ordeal
parents barely able to contain their joy
but aware
of the trauma their children have been
through i was crying
cry of joy because i just look at him
he looks emotional and he has one
in his honest on his leg there's a
hopping wood
on his leg and his leg is swelling on
december 11th gunmen on motorbikes
raided
this boarding school marching more than
300 boys
into a forest
this boy says the kidnappers gave them
very little food
another boy reported being repeatedly
beaten
the islamist militant group boko haram
had claimed responsibility
publishing this video of the boys but
local authorities maintained the captors
are just bandits the governor rang me
and informed me
president muhammadu buhari addressed the
boys on friday
this kidnapping happening in his home
state
far from where boko haram normally
operates in nigeria's
northeast that is where they took
276 girls in 2014
almost half of whom remain missing the
bring back our girls movement
continues to campaign for those students
it just took us actually that place
in that place that you know we've not
yet left there because we still have 112
of our cheap workers who are still in
captivity
and we still have parents so you know
who i had broken
aisha yasufu says the government has all
but forgotten
the girls right now schools are being
closed up
schools in sokoto uh containers of also
others
neighboring states they are closing down
schools our bodies schools have been
closer so at the end of the day the
terrorists have really won because what
they wanted
was that children shouldn't be in school
a sobering thought for the future of a
country where
100 million people are under the age of
18.
redmond shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the town of
winnipeg beach in manitoba
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you